all right now as we have been showing
you night after night failed far left
democratic leaders
they don't even literally follow their
own covet restrictions
even as they want the rest of us all of
you
to follow their draconian orders all of
them
rules for thee but not for me not for
you
that's been the driving motto of
prominent democrats
and we start with embattled governor
let's start with gavin newsom
who is now in the fight of his life and
the recall
race with poles now finally having him
underwater i guess enough covet
hypocrisy
has sunk into the people of california
but you may remember back in november
2020
remember he's caught at that group
dinner
ritzy french laundry restaurant
no masks no social distancing all while
well he's telling everyone else in
california that doing this would be
putting lives at risk
and that's not all his kids they were
back in person learning at school
while most of the rest of the state of
california their students
suffered under remote learning and just
recently he pulled his kids from
a summer camp after a massless photo
emerged there exposing more of newsom's
rampant disregard for his own rules and
of course
it doesn't even stop there he had one
more restaurant
incident and in michigan well there we
have failed governor
uh governor gretchen whitmer shut down
whitmer in michigan
she was caught lying about a trip to
florida while she was telling everybody
else
do not travel she falsely claimed that
she was in town she knew she wasn't
and then there's even more remember when
she was urging residents to stay home
last summer at the same time her husband
yeah he was trying to get a dock
installed at their
lake house and bring his boat out and
then there's disgrace governor andrew
cuomo not only
is he under fire to resign after the
damning
state ag report about a pattern of
sexual harassment against former and
current state female employees
a whopping total of 11 of them he also
just like whitmer ordered six patients
into nursing homes
and then cuomo got caught trying to
cover it all
up all while he inked a multi-million
dollar
book deal and the whistleblower within
his own administration actually said
yeah the reason we weren't telling you
the real numbers is because we didn't
want the department of justice to have
them
hmm sounds like a cover-up last fall he
was exposed for
this thanksgiving day plan saying that
his daughters and 89 year old mother
were coming to dinner
despite telling everyone else in new
york to avoid these gatherings before
eventually
having to cancel the dinner out of
embarrassment and then there's far
left socialist mayor well lori
lightweight
and violence plagued chicago and she
ramped up covert restrictions in that
city
all while she was appearing massless at
the
lalapalooza music festival in chicago
and don't forget about d.c mayor muriel
bowser
remember she was photographed massless
at a wedding reception
yeah right after she reinstated the
district's
mass mandate there and then of course
barack obama
yeah he had a big party planned his 60th
birthday
yeah he had to scale down his martha's
vineyard
birthday bash after it was revealed that
yeah he was going to have a party with
700 people
again ask yourself if these leaders
really were worried about covid and
they're putting these draconian measures
on
us you we the american people
would they be acting like this i don't
think so and that includes
the well cognitively struggling joe
biden back in march
the white house they were forced to
defend his weekend travels to delaware
as it came at the very same time the
administration was now urging americans
to avoid
all non-essential travel i don't think
delaware is essential
out in san francisco remember nancy
pelosi she got caught
getting her hair done at that hair salon
as it remained closed businesses shut
their doors they weren't allowed to open
legally
yeah they opened for her and i don't see
a mask on either
and more recently pelosi caught again
without her mask
after reinstating the mandate in the
house of representatives
we've seen this time and time and time
and time again for example the far left
mayor of austin texas
was a force to apologize for taking a
mexico vacation
at the same time urging residents to
stay
home and the san jose mayor said last
year that
he didn't know his thanksgiving
gathering broke state health rules
so ask yourself does any of this make
any sense
does anyone really believe that these
politicians
these so-called experts are at all
concerned
with all of our safety and our
well-being because
it's as undeniable as ever the biden
administration the democratic party
their friends in the media mob
they have politicized the science they
use it when it's convenient they ignore
it when it's convenient
and the consequences have been
devastating hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else